we're the grand canyon in the middle of
winter we didn't realize it was gonna be
this cold we knew it was gonna be chilly
this is a whole another level and we're
about to go on some mule rides but first
the sunrise
so right now we're debating on if we do
the mule rides or not because it is
extremely cold it says it's zero degrees
on my snapchat
but that's really cold i'm only using
snapchat
actually just to see what the
temperature was because said he would
actually use snapchat anymore
i'm not sure i didn't know we're
checking in
[Music]
we've decided to do the mule ride we're
packing up we're getting some breakfast
right now
and this is our our bag that we're going
to be putting our water in
for the ride because we're not allowed
to take bottled water thank you so much
commemorative cup on the mule ride this
is bread
it's so cold guys it's so cool we also
can't take selfie sticks so my entire
plan
is foiled
[Music]
go to the grand canyon jenna says go to
grand canyon it's gonna be great
wow is it cold there was a storm
there was a storm it was slightly
unexpected
but man it's beautiful like it is so
pretty
we're about to hop on the mules we
basically can't bring anything so
i'm kind of gonna strap my phone to my
body i'm gonna have to be holding on and
focusing on my mule
and my body and and not falling or
getting hurt
so i don't know what i'm gonna be able
to film
i haven't seen snow in a while we just
saw it
yeah but this is like legit snow with
the others no
i don't know jenna don't ask me
questions
all right it will be cold i mean like
really cold
so if you think you're going to be cold
at all or if you're not prepared
now's your time hop back down there but
it will be cold
look at them
[Music]
so here's the mules that we'll be riding
i think they're ready
this one right here is really rowdy he's
probably gonna end up being my mule
[Music]
[Applause]
so i thought it was gonna be like
vlogging and filming while i was on my
mule
we gotta drive it like i don't i gotta
control it i gotta motivate him i gotta
slap some butt
give it like stop it stop it
ah no that's my motivator we just got
our mule assignment
and you guys are not going to believe
this my mule's name is maddie like i
can't even i can't even make that up
very good
man of the mule maddie
[Music]
like
currently on our mule ride on our way to
our first stop
[Music]
look at this view
he looks like he's going to do something
my horse is eyeing up susie's horse
don't you even very nervous
is she mad at me no she just doesn't
respect you
so it's a me problem yeah
so far our ride is going very well my
mule has started to
behave a little bit better it's getting
colder but we're almost done but this
was so awesome the views are incredible
and surprise i'm so cold
but my mule maddie she's being a good
girl now check her out
marry my mule
[Music]
oh my god
okay we made it back to the stables and
man
i am just i just wow i had so much fun
it was a lot more fun than i thought as
soon as we started i was a little bit
terrified because maddie was not
listening to me
but she obeyed and now i think we're
best friends she's probably like i'm
glad this girl is off my back now
josie was very well behaved very
well-behaved
we had a very good time together mine
was not
so well behaved hello it's justine
reporting
back on the bus
so we just ate at this historic
restaurant there is a lot of history
here and they said that
all kinds of presidents have eaten here
lots of celebrities and of course
we meet jenna and susie yeah and to the
list
we got back from running the mules and
suzie's mule
it farted for a solid minute and a half
we were crying we got like the guy was
like
why are they crying he's like i've never
had anyone cry before i'm like i'm so
sorry they were laughing so hard i had
no idea when they were laughing well
this is why that would've been like
the john deere tractor
stole the clip that was my clip
you posted your video
there's a lot of cute little things here
oh some music some sounds of the canyon
this is so crazy guys there is oh the
canyon is grand
super grand
[Music]
remember when it snowed remember when i
slid down
a mountain at yosemite i do i was there
yep
what did you do jenna it's not attached
to me anymore
is it cracked no 21 baby
tech 21
so these two brothers they were they
went down the grand canyon in
a wood boat way back in the day and they
took this camera with them
they took pictures all along the way and
then they built this cabin here
and they would sell their pictures to
all the guests that came and stayed at
the grand canyon how nice the state at
the el tavor
but this is so cool because this is the
original house where they did their
dealings
yeah wow their cameras here
there they are the bros look they're
riding mules
we had such a fun day today now we're
here watching the sunset it is so
beautiful and still so cold i don't want
to keep talking about how cold it is
but i don't have anything else to talk
about because that's all i'm feeling
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning day two of the canyon
we are off to see the sunrise once again
and who knows what else is gonna happen
today because i never know
hello guys good morning is it gonna be
warmer today
a little bit i think it's already warmer
like right now than it was this time
yesterday
we stopped to mcdonald's to get some
coffee obviously
this is a much better sunrise than
yesterday already just because
we've got some coffee we've got the time
lapse app finally set up on my sony
camera it's so weird to just actually
download apps on the camera to be able
to use the time lapse feature so
i finally did it so let's see how it
works oh god the elevation i can't
[Music]
breathe
two different time lapses one on my
gopro and one on
my pony let me know which one you guys
like better
it's interesting because if they have
that sign there that means that someone
definitely has been drinking out of the
toilet so
i'm confused we're going to go to the
gift shop but get some things we just
need breakfast
and we're going to head off on more
adventures there's my sister jenna
i think it is from it's little mule it's
a little
he's going to love it no he's going to
love this i hiked grand canyon
yeah look the mule train mail oh
did you guys know that the grand canyon
is the only place that still delivers
mail by meal look
meal mail what does it put this in your
vlog
meal mints
let's get a postcard for mom and gram
mom dad and graham not that angry put
this in my room for ed
yes did i get him one before yes oh no
oh my god wait it says ed and it says
matt no way
best friends that's crazy that's not
right look there's two justin's but no
justine
can i get a justin for myself and just
etch my e into it
that's pretty oh i like it because it
looks like a stamp get that one
green candy snow candies no
let's see we've gone in here that's how
many animals
what are you what are you what are you
what are you so now coming up on a
watchtower we actually saw this from a
very very very very far distance
yesterday when we were riding the mules
and now we're seeing it up close hey you
cold
no i'm just tired we're all very tired
because we got up super early to see the
[Laughter]
sunrise
[Music]
so
in these sun rise above the mountains
over
[Music]
it's so much warmer in here than it is
outside nice little fireplace
nice little channel hello
right hey look out jen what are you
doing oh
oh oh it goes like this they're black
[Music]
mirrors
looks like the mario invincibility star
celebration man
oh wow i mean almost in
we've arrived at leipen this is
supposedly one of the best views in the
park and i'm not gonna lie
i think it definitely is just can't get
like it's so big that's what she said
i'm a she also just saw the reflection
of what i look like right now with this
hat on
it's super silly
we're packing up to leave we packed so
much i think that we thought that we
were actually camping in the grand
canyon but we weren't at all
we didn't really even make it down
inside of the canyon now they're all
packed we're gonna head back
and drive for about eight hours maybe
even longer because once we get that la
traffic
it's very unexpected oh hello
[Music]
2 43 p.m no three what
it's three forty-eight it's three four
we get an hour back we do it
yes wow
it's christmas the little things the
drive begins now
so it's five minutes later 3
we're at our first stop
i can't i can't make this up we're at
starbucks oh look at this cactus
wow these are so cool
cactus arizona monks hello
oh you're actually fine i think i'm fine
jenna doesn't want me to drive i'm not
sure why
we're gonna go to wendy's i just had a
yerba mate and i'm feeling super
super silly we're listening to whitney
houston
currently winning i want to go to
wendy's i really want to get a single
patty
with mayo and lettuce should we go we
got it we got to go to weddings can we
let's go
you gotta chill oh my god there it is
i've been waiting so long
no no no we're going to wendy's put on
weddings there's no carl's jr yes there
is no let's get
it how do i get there turn right there
that's the highway turn
no adults are in there this is why
you're right not driving
i'm like i get back on the ice i'm going
the wrong way i got it oh i'm going to
get a frog i'm not going to get a
problem
get french fries i always go oh yes
french do they have a kid's meal i would
love a kid's meal
you know they're not going to put
hamburgers in happy meals anymore
and that's because that's because
they're trying to be more health
conscious
so take out all the food here you can
have some fruit
oh yes look at you what do you guys want
oh i'll get you anything you want
large fry oh large fries guess what it's
my turn to drive
i got a single with mayo and and cheese
and lettuce
oh look at our little sandwiches and our
fries great let's go guys i just filmed
this whole piece
about i was so excited for my french
fries i showed them in the bag
and then i looked at my camera i wasn't
filming so it's really not even that
riveting of content but we've got our
wendy's we've got four hours left
i think jenna's gonna make me drive now
i always got you i'm ready to drive
so approximately i would say like maybe
three hours ago or two hours ago how
long ago did we stop at wendy's an hour
ago
an hour longer an hour it's been like an
hour now okay well now we're at
mcdonald's i'm gonna get a shamrock
shake because i'm driving
it's like a minty
[Music]
this is a lot of green this is something
that we're unfortunately i'm gonna see
later today
or tomorrow i gotta get home we gotta
get home we gotta get home
we're not well after 9pm i get silly
[Music]
you